so why don't we just start off as like
what is a database it's like kind of an
existential question it's like what is
life you know it's like I don't I don't
know it's kind of a very deep thing so
like if we think about like what's the
simplest kind of database is a file
right maybe we have a CSV file maybe we
have just binary data we have JSON in it
you know the file is kind of like the
most simple as stupid as database we
could have and then you know we can move
up a level right and we have things that
are like key value stores we have things
like level DB Berkeley DB rocks DV where
they're just like really really simple
key value stores on binary data right
and we keep moving up the hierarchy
right and then we have something like
sequel Lite where like now we have
concepts of tables we have transaction
logs and we even have a query language
sequel which everybody loves and
everybody wants sequel everywhere and
then we keep moving to where most people
in the audience are probably building
their systems at which is like my sequel
or Postgres we're like okay cool we have
a web app we have some micro services
and we have my sequel Postgres right and
pretty much the majority of the audience
is probably sitting here right now
saying I have this this is good for me
and I think for most startups like if
you have like a 5-10 person team maybe
you only have 10,000 20,000 users this
is fine but you know like once we start
getting into really interesting use
cases like let's say that you have to
track millions of servers or you have
your Facebook and you need to have tons
of users or maybe you're trying to build
your own blockchain there's lots of
really interesting use cases where we
might want to build our own custom
database and that's kind of what we're
going to go into today so just really
quick about me founder of loom network
we build blockchain software before that
I used to build time series databases at
digitalocean I've been in the NGO
community for so long I can't even
remember actually how long I've been in
it and I live in Thailand so I had a
really short fly I know some people flew
here all the way from Miami so um
jealous of that flights it's cool
awesome cool
so I think the first thing that's gonna
jump out to everybody there like Matt
why do I need to distribute a database
if I need one I'll use Cassandra I'll
use BigTable I'll use redshift all these
solutions
I say yeah sure those are pretty cool so
like when when I was at digitalocean we
built our own metrics database and we
built one that could track millions and
millions of servers on top of Cassandra
but when you build on top of something
like Cassandra or a BigTable you start
to run into like two big issues let's
say that you want a query data in a
custom way you want to have indexes that
are not normal
you have to have indexes for every
single use case that you could possibly
ever imagine and you don't have a query
language or you have a very simplistic
query language so like let's say that
you wanted to have a very
domain-specific query language beyond
sequel like so for example we had a
metrics creating language so you could
aggregate metrics across different
machines all these kinds of things are
almost impossible to do on top of
Cassandra so that's where we get into
like actually wanting to build our own
database so what are some of like the
really the core use cases I think
blockchains
so I'm a bit biased so I'm a big
blockchain guy right now and but I think
block chains are one of the coolest new
kinds of databases so really block
chains are just distributed databases
but they're actually super secure so
basically that anybody can write into
them as long as they pay fees so we'll
get into that more later stock trading
is really cool so when I used to work at
Bloomberg we actually had custom time
series databases so that way when you're
doing trades like the the tickers can be
very fast logging and metric systems I
think this is like one of the biggest
areas obviously I'm a bit biased because
I've worked on multiple metrics
databases but I think this has been a
really cool area where new databases
have come up yeah so who here knows
anything about the blockchain or Bitcoin
or has used it at all
come on a few people like three people
in the audience they're like okay cool
the second-largest blockchain in the
world is written and go so that's
there's thirty thousand nodes running go
right now and that's not including all
the users that are actually connecting
it to so like this is actually one of
the biggest use cases of go and most
people don't even realize that this is
like this is like a pretty big
application you know what are some of
the other big projects written and go I
was trying to list it out and I ran at
space on the slide there's so many
databases written and go there in
production right now I think probably
everybody in this room knows like in
flux DB and Prometheus like I was saying
we wrote our own at digitalocean
aetherium blockchains at CD console
there's just I can't I could go on
forever about how many databases are
written and go so awesome
you're like Matt awesome you convinced
me these distributed databases are so
cool I want to make my own how does it
work what do I need to do how do I sign
up for this cool all right let's start
so let's actually just look at the
architecture of what a distributed
database looks like and this is like
really simplistic and we're kind of like
break down into each one of these pieces
and you don't have to stare at this too
long we're gonna break into it but
there's many different components and
before we actually look at a distributed
system we should look at my sequel
because this is the main one that most
people are using so well you'll see is
my sequel has a storage layer and it has
transaction logs but you as a developer
you never know about the actual key
value store so when you use my sequel
you always pick something like nodb
which is just basically a transactional
key value store but there's all these
layers that are actually taking your
sequel statements and converting them
into like key value store lookups or
range lookups on indexes and my sequel
is doing this all in the background for
you so let's start
the various the very bottom level of
building a distributed database which is
consensus so let me go ahead and start
this diagram this little movie here so
consensus is basically saying how do we
make multiple machines agree about state
changes so this is actually a diagram
from raft which is one of the which is
one of the consensus implementations and
basically what happens is generally
speaking there's a single leader for a
portion of the data set and that leader
will broadcast changes to the other
nodes and basically once they become an
agreement they can commit that data and
then new data can be moved on so like
that's the lowest layer and this is
actually one of the more complicated
layers but what's really kind of cool
isn't go we can just take there's three
different go rafting two implementations
so you don't need to know anything about
consensus you can just take the SCD raft
layer and boom you have a consensus
system that allows you to get
distributed transaction distributed stay
spread across the system there's two
other kind of consensus systems that I
like to talk about so the original is
this is all kind of based on this
original paper called Paxos which is
kind of like the father of all these
consensus systems but now raft is like a
very simplified version and there's
something really cool which is called
Byzantine fault tolerance and that's
where like Bitcoin and blockchain come
in because they're actually a version of
distributed databases where there's a
lot less trust involved whereas with
raft and Paxos they generally assume
that there's no bad actors in the system
and that each of the nodes is typically
not going to try to lie to the other
nodes so like if you want to have a
system where like you have a public
database where multiple people are using
it you might want to consider something
like a Byzantine fault-tolerant system
so like I mentioned for for like if we
were going to start at our consensus
layer the Hashi core craft
implementation is probably the fact
one right now that most people use but
the etsy d1 is still quite it's quite
usable so so we're at the bottom layer
and I know I'm kind of jumping through
this because I'm like 25 minute talk
here but like once we have consensus and
basically once we have the agreement
that like for example like a user puts
his email address into the database all
the nodes agree that they have that
email address well we still have we have
to store that onto disk now right so now
we need to have some kind of key value
store on top of that that actually
stores all this information and we also
have these things called transaction
locks so when we think of tables and
like databases typically like we're not
actually getting we're not actually a
table is really just a materialized view
of all the transactions and what do I
mean is that like let's say that a user
creates an account and then the user
like changes his email address or he
changes his name each one of those each
update or insert statement is a
transaction and all those are in a
transaction log and eventually they move
into your primary key value store which
is like then we can actually query at
and we can make things like tables and
materialized views on top of and there's
like amazing amount of choices so the
one we use internally is we use this
thing called level DB so in flux DB was
using level DB for a while
atheria muses level DB it's probably the
most popular and basically all it is is
a key value store that's it it's a
single node single user key value store
and basically you build all the
constructs on top of it so you would
take your PDP layer and as you're
getting consensus among nodes you can
actually write things into this key
value store and you see Matt yeah and
this is a lot of work I just did all
this work to like replicate it a simple
key value store and I'm not even at the
point of where I would be with Cassandra
it really gets interesting when we get
to the query layer so right now most
database systems
or queried using sequel but if you take
the Prometheus project I love this tweet
from one of the Prometheus developers if
you were to try to write a sequel
language for querying metrics you would
have to write like a dozen lines of code
to be able to like query metrics across
a couple machines they actually wrote
their own querying language in go and
wrote their own lexer and parser and
they were able to make a very
domain-specific language and I think
this is where we're going to see more
and more interesting applications where
like we can actually build our own query
languages for different domains like if
we're in the stock markets we could
actually make a language that is
actually specific to looking at stock
tickers or time series data and these
kinds of things and there's quite a bit
of good implementations of the query
layer so actually on the go Academy
website I found it's quite old but
there's actually a great article about
how to build your own parser and lexer
and it actually shows you in like a
hundred lines of code how to write your
own sequel parser which I didn't think
was going to be so simple but you can
basically go from there
and like for example on my team we have
like our own querying languages for
block chains and then the other great
examples are in the past we use the
Prometheus query language and then in
Flex DB has their own query language
they're all open source and go I mean
this is probably one of the one areas
that's a little bit more tricky and go
but I have to say these are some of the
most interesting pieces of source you'll
ever look at I think it's really
exciting that we could go beyond sequel
like I think the world is being held
back but just doing sequel everywhere
it's cool so tying this together like
like we get these little pieces together
we get we get our we have our p2p layer
we have our raft we have our level DB
and now we've created our own
domain-specific language and now we can
actually build applications on top of
this and I think this is where it's kind
of cool like for example like with
aetherium the blockchain they actually
build applications that run inside the
database so you can actually deploy
new pieces of virtual machine code into
the database and they get run inside the
database and the results get committed
back into the database so then all of a
sudden the application and the database
like merge into one like a transformers
and I think there's a lot of really cool
applications for like when you need
really high-performance systems and you
don't want your application and your
database to be merged and but this keeps
coming back so I was actually one of the
co-founders originally on in flux TB and
we started it originally on top of
Cassandra and we found that like we
couldn't get the performance we wanted
so eventually we ended up merging it
down into a go binary and that's
actually how in flux DB started is that
it was a very custom it was actually for
specific metrics application and it
turned out that it was it was able to be
generalized for anybody wanting to build
metrics based systems gotcha
so obviously I'm talking a lot of
flowery logic about building distributed
systems and these is way harder than
building your typical microservice
architecture right because these are
very stateful systems you have failures
that basically every point like each
server you could have corrupted data you
could have transactions that are not
being propagated you can have network
you can have network splits so this is
like very complicated stuff so like
definitely like you want to isolate the
number of use cases you want to use this
in but I think there's like a lot of
opportunities though so for my
experiences I kind of gone into them the
the project that we're working on now is
like we're actually building like custom
blockchain software and go and we're
trying to make it really easy for go
developers to build their own blockchain
strain and we're actually like actually
building like Byzantine fault-tolerance
and what we're seeing is is that like
it's pretty cool that like you can you
can build that you have a whole binary
and you stick it on a machine and it has
all the logic for your application and
your database in one
then you can replicate that to a hundred
other machines across the world and then
they can all be part of one database and
trust each other
so what are the main takeaways here is
that I think that we're gonna see a lot
more custom databases written and go I
hope that like I know this was a very
high-level talk but I kind of wanted to
get everybody into the concepts of like
building a database where to get started
what libraries you need to use and like
the basic concepts and feel free to grab
me and this is what I've been working on
for the last five years so I'm really
excited about building these systems and
last thing we're definitely hiring so if
you guys want to work on blockchains
distributed databases and I think I have
a few minutes for questions here